Um, so my special does come out.
Uh it's out now. And, uh,
my brother did direct it and I just want to say I'm really fortunate, man.
I really am fortunate. Sure. I worked hard and stuff,
but I'm really lucky to be in the position that I am. Um,
and I realized that and I try, I do think about that a lot and,
and my brother directed this special and it's just so cool that he did it
because I love him. And, um,
I mean, I really love him. Like,
it's so awesome to have somebody like that.
Like people always say like, how many kids you want to have? And I'm like, uh,
two's good because I had one brother and no sisters and no other brother
and everything that I didn't could
couldn't talk to anybody about.
I would do it with Matt because he was the only guy and that
bond because of that is awesome.
Now I'm not saying if you have three brothers or two sisters and a brother or
whatever, you don't have that. But for me,
I always felt cool that there was one other person that I can
confide in and just know that that was down a ride. And so as I, for him,
and of course I had an open, uh, you know, family with my mom, my dad,
I could talk to them about everything. I mean, the first time I, I, I,
I masturbated, I walked down and I told them and I walked down and I saw,
and I was crying for real dude. I was a. And I,
and I said to my mom and my mom said, what the hell is wrong?
She was eating like jelly beans. My mom would always eat the jelly beans.
And she would shuck them around her hand a little bit before she popped them in
her mouth due to drove me nuts. I was like,
why don't you just pick them up and eat them?
What if they make it a game like that? He needs a new pair of shoes. Hey,
there we go. But I was crying and she was like, what's wrong? And I said,
it happened. And I thought she knew what I was going to talk about.
And she said, what? And I said calming. And she said, Oh, go upstairs.
And dad's coming home in 10 minutes.
And that was when I got to talk about the birds and the bees.
And that is beautiful, but anything I couldn't bring up,
I would talk to my brother about. And, you know,
I assume my brother did the same thing to me. We never hated each other.
You know, I think he went through some weird because, uh,
I was the older brother and just, you know,
it's weird when you're growing up with an older brother,
I feel like you probably have to like, you know, he did,
I did everything first, you know? And then the, the second kid is like, okay,
the second kid, we, we, we learned our mistakes and it's, you know, it's like,
if you have 11 kids, 11 kid is just like, Oh yeah, what's his name again?
You know? So, um,
I feel like a really cool that my brother,
I, I feel lucky that my brother directed it because he's great.
First of all, he's talented. Um, but besides that,
I love him and I genuinely love him deeply.
And to have him a part of this experience helps me, you know,
I mean, it was that way with my dad too. It was the coolest thing he was in. Uh,
he was in, uh, the van. I remember when I shot my first special,
he was in the van with the headphones on and I knew out there onstage,
he was proud of me in that van, you know,
and I would think about that while I was doing my special while I was talking to
those people in new Orleans. And, uh,
I got in my head a little bit with standup through, uh, the years,
like in cordial, I felt good about,
and then I started getting a little bit insecure because I didn't know what else
to talk about.
Man of fire was something that came up after Uncage was my third special and the
material I had, I loved, but I just wasn't in a good place in my life.
And my dad directed it and it was great and I'm really proud of it.
And it was still in my head. I shot at comedians of the world.
I really liked the way it came out. I, I don't, I'm lucky to have,
uh, what I have, and I'm lucky to have shot what I have shot in my career,
but man, uh, but this special, uh, no pain,
which is one of the reasons why it's called no pain.
Cause people always say pink comedy comes from pain,
but I didn't really experience much of that in my life. And, um,
I'm fortunate for that. And I always used to think that it was,
it would make me insecure, uh,
as it made me insecure that I didn't have that real to talk about as a comedian.
And, um, and this one is just like, all that
I have what I have. And I'm really lucky and I'm really fortunate.
And I'm going to talk about what the I'm going to talk about.
And I'm like, I have my dad, I'm like, I have a mom. I'm like,
I have my own family, you know, and my brother directed it.
And that's a real special thing for me, man. And, uh, so, you know,
thank you Matt for doing it. Uh, and um, you made it great.
Um, you know, it's cool to have a support system.
Um, I dunno, I dunno if that's what you wanted, not wanting to hear. I mean,
sometimes I talk like that and then people ended up being like, you bro,
because, Oh, you don't know what real pain is. And it's like, okay.
But some people, you know, I look,
I'm just trying to be honest with you guys sometimes.
Um, but yeah, so I'm excited.
I'm really excited. And, uh, thanks for, uh,
to everybody that ever has come out to see me and supported me online.
Or even if you haven't come out to see me, if you just tell somebody I'm funny,
that's so cool. And I appreciate it.